[Music]
begin with breaking news on Al Jazeera
from the occupied West Bank Israeli
forces have shot and killed a
Palestinian after he opened fire on an
illegal Israeli settlement and killed a
security guard we can go straight down
Shazier's Alan Fisher and Ramallah Alan
this is a rapidly developing story and
it broke in just the last few moments
what have you been able to gather so far
well most of the information that we're
getting in the last out or so is coming
from Israeli Army Radio what we can tell
you is that we believe that a
Palestinian was driving near to the
settlement of ketamine when he got out
of his car and opened fire at this stage
we're told he killed a security guard
and injured one other that other person
is in a serious condition now nearby
Army operation was alerted and they
moved to the scene and chased the
Palestinian into a nearby Field where in
the words of the Israeli Army he was
neutralized which essentially means he
was killed the ketamine is a settlement
probably about an hour's drive away from
Janine where of course we saw so much
activity over the last few days and is
also the home of better cell smotherich
who is the Israeli Finance Minister we
are being told that the checkpoints that
run between nablis which is nearby about
an hour or so drive from kirimim and
ketamine at a closed down for the moment
which of course is going to bring a
great deal of hardship for The Hundreds
who are currently on the road trying to
get to various towns and Villages nearby
but just to repeat what we have found
out in the last hour a Palestinian
opened fire on an illegal Israeli
settlement killing one security guard
injuring one other person they're said
to be serious the Israeli Army responded
by shooting the Palestinian he is now
dead
Alan
put this in context for us if you will
you were heading our coverage of the
latest round of violence which was the
Israeli assault on the Palestinian
refugee camp of Janine
and the Israelis had stepped up their
security precautions because they were
fearful that there could be attacks in
their area uh we of course had a the
attack in uh in Tel Aviv just a couple
of days ago where there was a car
running and the Palestinian there was
shot dead uh so they they were aware
that this was a possibility
um but the if you look at the figures
over the course of the year uh the
number of dead Palestinians in the
occupied West Bank and Gaza up to this
year so far
195 for the moment with the death of the
security guard
that means that 29 Israelis have been
killed but certainly it will alert uh
settler communities across the the West
Bank and there will be increased
security there in the coming hours that
is is a given Alan just before I let you
go to gather more information on all of
this um a word from you perhaps on bezel
smartridge you mentioned that kidumin
the settlement that was just targeted is
the home of bezel small Church you
mentioned he's the Finance Minister he's
not just the Finance Minister of course
he has extensive power over what happens
in the occupied West Bank namely
settlement building so I think that's an
important part of this
but it may just be a coincidence as well
it may just be uh to use a phrase from
another place in another time it just
may be the opportunity opened up I I and
it could well be that but the fact that
that smotherages there is worth noting
simply because he is one of what would
be regarded as the extreme right-wing
voices in the Israeli cabinet and the
fact that he is also a settler and at
this settlement is certainly newsworthy
just from that point of view
Alan Fisher reporting from Ramallah
thank you very much and your point is
well taking of course that that may be
coincidence that the settlement that was
just attacked is the home of pesles may
or may not be thank you very much Alan
for your coverage we'll let you go and
gather more news